who else will join Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine in Deadpool 3. the Hulk maybe
Captain America he is everything we want
to see when the Merc of the mouth
returns money was first announced that
Hugh Jackman will be back as Wolverine
it may have brought about the same sense
of excitement as when actor Josh Brolin
was revealed to be taking on the role of
cable in Deadpool 2. while his portrayal
of the futuristic cyborg Warrior was
well received many might have been
disappointed that the film put cable
into the role of villain for much of its
run time many fans are hoping that
Deadpool 3 producers won't be tempted to
do the same with Wolverine by pitting
the Merc with a mouth against the old
canucklehead instead making the film a
true team up given the friendship
between actors Ryan Reynolds and Hugh
Jackman we then suspect that Wolverine
will be Deadpool's enemy though we do
expect to see at least one fight scene
between the two at some point in the
film seeing the two blade wielding
mutants with the fastest healing factors
slicing and dicing away at one another
will surely be a fun sight but if the
film is smart everyone suspense with the
Rivalry quickly and make Wolverine and
Deadpool Fast Friends reluctant allies
and a hard-hitting Duo worthy of
Jackman's return
we work as a team they may adopt a
popular storyline from the comics that
saw the pair of X-Men join forces or
invent something new for fans to get
excited about but a proper team up that
lets us see the actors impeccable
on-screen chemistry might be what fans
want to see most out of Deadpool 3. with
the third Deadpool film no under the
Walt Disney Banner it's now a realistic
possibility for us to see the inclusion
of characters from the MCU we're not
sure if that will mean the movie will
take place within the Avengers universe
or see Deadpool travel through alternate
Dimensions but we fully anticipate at
least a couple of MCU cameos but what we
want to see most as a reunion of the
classic Avengers team including the
returns of Iron Man Captain America and
Black Widow though all three characters
have met their end in the MCU this is
Deadpool we're talking about a series
where anything goes and nothing has to
make sense if anything could get Chris
Evans or Robert Downey Jr to make their
way back into costume we could see them
doing it for Deadpool 3. a film that
convinced Hugh Jackman to and retire and
Dawn his claws once again whether it's
for a big action sequence or a blink and
Mystic Cameo like James mcavoy's X-Men
and Deadpool 2 a reunion of Avengers
Stars feels like the right choice the
chance of Wolverine to meet them is a
cherry on top of the Sunday even if it's
just something silly a comeback for our
dearly departed Heroes is what we're
hoping for we probably speak for all
fans when we say there's one superficial
elements that we selfishly want to see
for no other reason than it's sheer
coolness that element is a comic
accurate costume for Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine this remarkable is a thing
that Jackman appeared as a character for
nearly 20 years but never wore any kind
of outfit that even vaguely resembled
his traditional comic book costume and
never once Dante's iconic winged face
mask in the most curiously overlooked
aspect of the Maverick multi-clawed
mutants fans were teased with a possible
yellow and black costume in a deleted
scene from The Wolverine however this
scene was only included in the home
release of the film thus audiences
missed out on seeing it in action
because we never picked up his story
from that point with both days of future
past and Logan taking place at various
points across the timeline of course it
would be just like Ryan Reynolds to know
this is exactly what audiences want to
see and play it for a joke constantly
teasing a costume that never comes but
in the end putting wolvey in costume is
far too tempting for the notoriously
fun-loving Reynolds and would be too
crowd-pleasing a moment for him not to
include it though we can't consider this
one a lock we think it's more than
likely the filmmakers deliver
you afraid you might like it when it
comes to matchups between a pair of
Heroes few can stop Wolverine and the
Incredible Hulk a rivalry that began
back in Wolverine's first appearance in
The Incredible Hulk issue 181 by the
late 2000s both characters have made
their way to the big screen with Jackman
making Wolverine famous and the Hulk
appearing in two films of his own before
Mark Ruffalo took on the role beginning
with the superhero team-up film The
Avengers while rights issues have kept
the characters apart it hasn't stopped
fans from dreaming about a showdown
between the two actors as their iconic
characters following Disney's
acquisition of fox though fans began to
wonder if their dreams could come true
with Jackman's mutant finally coming to
blows with ruffalo's monster hope seemed
Dash when Jackman doubled down on his
retirement from the role in 2017 after
the release of Logan but with the Aussie
actor changing his mind and coming back
for Deadpool 3 we want to see the
matchup finally happen as it could be
our last chance for the Hulk and
Wolverine to meet while these two actors
are in the roles if you ask Mark Ruffalo
it could happen going by his comments on
the Marvel list podcast in 2018 he said
I love you and it would be cool to do
something with him if he's up to doing
it he's always sees Hulk vs Wolverine
would be pretty fun
if Ryan Reynolds and writes us Paul
wernick and Reese are looking to adapt
the story from the comics one that saw
Deadpool and Wolverine team up the
answer is clearly The Good the Bad and
the Ugly named after the iconic Clint
Eastwood's spaghetti western the 2013
storyline ran in the pages of Deadpool
issue 15-19 full of Deadpool's customary
humor and saw Wade Wilson unless the aid
of both Wolverine and Captain America in
investigating new information regarding
the Weapon X Program though a movie
adaptation would likely amidst Captain
America or maybe not now that Deadpool's
under the MCU Banner it would be easy
enough to substitute the Sentinel of
Liberty with a character like Colossus
or even cable but while the
investigation in two Weapon X could be
compelling it also could be a little
played out having been a part of
multiple X-Men films instead what we
really love about this story is the
spark that sets it off as a mysterious
villain is caught repeatedly stealing
Deadpool's organs while the weapon x
angle might be a nice idea to get the
two Heroes together an organ theft plot
that sees is that ball calling Wolverine
for help seems like the kind of
sickeningly Twisted story that Reynolds
would enjoy when the dust settled on the
acquisition of 20th Century Fox for the
Walt Disney Company in 2019 fans went
into a frenzy anticipating a reboot of
the X-Men films and their Universe
within the greater Marvel Cinematic
Universe butt has been now and we have
yet to see anything from the world of
mutants and the MCU with a few
exceptions including locations like
madrapore and the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier however we may be in for a long
wait as Marvel has revealed its plans
for Phase 5 of the MCU with no X-Men on
the calendar through at least 2025 but
we know they're coming eventually so why
not include a direct reference to a new
team of MCU mutants in Deadpool 3 to wet
our Collective appetites
She-Hulk is a bit more of a long shot
especially considering the divisive
family reaction to the Disney plus
series but that's been told that
She-Hulk will be making her way to the
big screen eventually according to the
direct so there's no reason she can't
get a head start with an appearance in
Deadpool 3. a long time fourth wall
breaker Jennifer Walters habit of
turning to the camera and talking
directly to the audience predates
Deadpool in the comics and continues to
be used to Great comedic effect in her
own series We Believe seeing them
sharing the screen and arguing over
which one is going to get the audience's
attention would be a recipe for comedy
gold and while much of the silliness and
She-Hulk may not have been a hit with
audiences her tongue-in-cheek humor
could feel right at home in Deadpool
where a twerk or a bruh might not be out
of place
bruh plus if we do get a Hulk Wolverine
Showdown who better to break it up than
Bruce's cousin who can mock the overly
macho boys for always finding a reason
to fight amongst themselves heading into
the release of Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness many fans were
hoping for a parade of former movie
guest stars there were Big Dreams of
seeing non-mcu Heroes like Nicholas
Cage's Ghost Rider or Wesley Snipes
Blade back in Action across the
Multiverse there was even brief talk of
new versions of the Avengers with rumor
swirling of Tom Cruise suiting up as
Iron Man gossip that turned out to be
entirely made up
nice ultimately though the film limited
his guest appearance says to the
Illuminati in a single key sequence
disappointing many but if Deadpool is
truly going to embrace the weirdness of
being under the Disney and MCU banners
cameos from Heroes from past movie
universes will be the perfect card to
play admittedly we don't want dead ball
3 to get bogged down in cameos but that
doesn't mean they can't give them to us
in Spades while keeping the movie
focused on a streamlined story after all
there's no better franchise to utilize
one-off appearances from a gaggle of
Multiverse Heroes than this one where a
joke can be played for a laugh before
moving on a Cavalcade of cameos would
finally fulfill every Fan's fantasies
the opportunity to have Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine finally share the screen with
the likes of Yuan Griffiths Mr Fantastic
or even Ben Affleck's Daredevil in
single scene gags might be too tempting
to pass up the internet and social media
have been blowing up since the
announcement that Hugh Jackman will be
back as Wolverine for Deadpool 3. hordes
of fans have been assembling their wish
lists of cameos and matchups but in all
these assignments over the unprecedented
access the filmmakers have to any number
of Marvel heroes we want to make sure
they don't forget that Deadpool already
has an excellent Supporting Cast that's
right with all the talks centered on
Wolverine let's remember there are
plenty of great characters from the
first two films who want to see back in
Action that includes disgruntled cabbie
dopinder lucky Domino steel-skinned
Colossus sardonic roommate blind Al and
the jaded negasonic teenage Warhead heck
we might even get to see Firestarter
Rusty Collins and time traveling mutant
cable 2. let's face it we want to see
cameos but only as long as a film
doesn't get sidetracked so far that it
forgets about old favorites some fans
might worry that so many characters will
hurt the film but Marvel has excelled
with large Ensemble casts before and
even a solo film or two with plenty of
guests they can watch Captain America
Civil War or Spider-Man no way home if
they want to see how to do it right
no joke we want to see Kevin feige yes
we mean the president of Marvel Studios
the master of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and the man with the famous
baseball cap we want to see him in
Deadpool 3. how and why you ask for
starters he's a king of all things
Marvel movies and it's long past due
that the fans get a chance to show their
love Deadpool 3 the first film to firmly
cross over the X-Men and MCU universes
with a sense of good humor is just the
right place for it to happen don't
forget Marvel Comics founder Stan Lee
has had cameos and nearly every major
Marvel movie and with his passing in
2018 maybe Marvel can pass the torch to
feige the founder of the MCU a movie
that doesn't just break the fourth wall
but smashes through it could easily see
it start breaking down feige's door and
demanding answers when he finds himself
in the MCU unaware of Disney's purchase
of 20th Century Fox it might even
combine our wish for an X-Men reboot
seize with the studio head knee-deep in
franchise planning when we see him
that'll do
[Music]